[Musique]
les accueils de joueurs sont des lieux
de vie qui ont pour objectif de
préserver et maintenir les capacités des
personnes atteintes de pathologies
cognitives associées à des troubles de
la mémoire grâce à des activités
adaptées en plus d'un lien social cela
permet aux bénéficiaires de rester le
plus longtemps possible dans leur cadre
de vie habituel si vous aussi l'accueil
de jour vous intéresse suivez-moi
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous partons à la rencontre
des époux Mora lina a des troubles de la
mémoire depuis quelques années et
plusieurs fois par semaine elle se rend
dans un accueil de jour loriapas ces
lieux de vie sont destinés à des
personnes de plus de 60 ans souffrant de
troubles de la mémoire en situation de
perte
bonjour Lina bonjour monsieur alors
dites-nous Lina quelles sont les
activités que vous pratiquez ici en
arrivant ici et bien on passe à table
notre petit goûter on commence à
travailler un petit peu quand même si
vous voulez faire une fleur ou bien si
vous voulez faire d'autres choses vous
pouvez les faire et pourquoi c'est
important de venir ici à Lorient pas
mais ici ça me fait du bien grand bien
on chante on dit beaucoup de choses des
choses qu'il est intéressant en tout cas
quand je la reprends le soir ben tout
est merveilleux quoi beaucoup des gens
ici que je connaissais pas j'ai fait la
connaissance et je suis heureuse merci
monsieur Morin
les accueils de jour adaptent leur
accompagnement à chaque personne
accueillie en proposant par groupe
restreint et homogène de nombreuses
activités qui s'intègrent dans le projet
de vie de la personne âgée et respecte
son rythme de vie ses activités
favorisent les stimulations physiques
sensorielles et cognitives et contribue
au bien-être des visiteurs bonjour
Jennifer alors dites-nous comment
s'inscrire pour pouvoir bénéficier de
l'accueil de jour
il faut se rendre auprès des
établissements qui proposent l'accueil
de jour donc pour connaître les
modalités et déposer un dossier et c'est
l'établissement qui traitera de ce
dossier donc l'accueil de jour c'est
pour un public qui souffre de maladies
d'Alzheimer ou de ne pathologie
neurodégénérative faut savoir qu'il
existe six accueils de jour sur l'île
répartis sur chaque micro-région donc et
on espère d'ici quelques années avoir
une quinzaine d'accueils de jours qui
s'ouvriront et combien coûte l'accueil
de jour le prix de l'accueil des joueurs
va différencier selon les établissements
mais il faut compter en moyenne 40 euros
par an sachant qu'il y a une prise en
charge partielle qui peut se faire au
travers de la location personnalisée
d'autonomie ou encore au travers de
l'Aide Sociale à l'ABS
alors il y a pas l'accueil et
l'animation sont assurés par une équipe
pluridisciplinaire composée d'une
infirmière coordinatrice d'aide
médico-psychologique est une
psychomotricienne l'équipe coordonnée
par un médecin est formé aux bonnes
pratiques gériatriques et spécifiquement
à l'accompagnement des personnes
atteintes de maladies d'Alzheimer ou
maladie à parenté bonjour Laurence
bonjour Alexandre alors dites-nous
comment se déroule une journée typique
ici alors ici on arrive le matin et on
est accueilli autour d'un petit café
puis s'enchaîne avec un petit atelier
cet atelier est souvent de l'activité
physique adaptée parce que conserver
l'autonomie est essentielle deuxième
atelier en deuxième partie de matinée
plus plus créatif et on embrait avec un
dernier atelier l'autokin domino
pourquoi est-ce important de maintenir
un lien avec les familles le lien est
essentiel une fois ce lien de confiance
créée on est entre guillemets une
béquille qui fait que le maintien de
missile peut exister très bien merci
Laurence
si vous souhaitez en savoir davantage
sur l'accueil de jour n'hésitez pas les
coordonnées s'affichent en ce moment
même sur votre écran le département des
générations s'est déjà fini si vous
souhaitez revoir cet épisode ainsi que
les précédents rendez-vous sur nos sites
et nos réseaux sociaux quant à moi je
vous retrouve très vite pour un nouvel
épisode à bientôt
la semaine prochaine nous rencontrerons
Eugénie qui a pu accompagner son enfant
en métropole afin de subir des soins
médicaux grâce au dispositif nommé
accompagnement des malades cette aide a
été mise en place par le département
afin d'apporter un soutien psychologique
et un repère aux malades
[Musique]